[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja
Haali schönen guten Abend Weitsicht
Planungssicherheit und Zuverlässigkeit
all das sind Dinge die Bürger und auch
Unternehmen von politisch erwarten und
auch erwarten können Problem ist bloß
dass die ampelregierung all das nicht
liefert denn mal wieder scheint die
Regierung sich selbst zu zerlegen die
Einigung in Sachen Haushalt ist noch
keine Woche alt da stellen Politiker aus
allen drei Parteien den mühsam
gefundenen Kompromiss wieder in Frage
vielleicht liegt das an der Wut einer
starken wie wichtigen Wählergruppe
nämlich die Landwirte sie haben heute
lautstark gegen die Streichung der
agrardeselsubvention protestiert und
abgekriegt hat den Frust der grüne
Landwirtschaftsminister man möchte fast
sagen ausgerechnet der
Landwirtschaftsminister aus Berlin
Britta
Spickermann die Wut kommt am frühen
Morgen mit hunderten PS nach Berlin
direkt zum Brandenburger Tor so viele
Traktoren können ein politisches Beben
verursachen wenn das wirklich kommt
Subvention Weg für Agrardiesel obend
drauf noch eine KFZ Steuer für
landwirtschaftliche F Zeuge dann gibt es
für diese Bauern nur ein Urteil eure
Politik ist unser
Tod ist jetzt der Tropfen zu viel
gewesen und das Fass ist nicht nur
übergelaufen sondern ist geborsten für
die junge Generation die jetzt
Landwirtschaft betreiben will in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten dass den gerade die
Perspektive und die Zukunft genommen
wird der bauernpräsident wütet wir
nehmen das nicht hin und zu viel ist zu
viel entweder Wechsel die Regierung
ihren oder und das habe ich schon in der
Rede gesagt muss es einen
Regierungswechsel geben öd mir
verspricht sich bei der eigenen
Regierung stark zu machen für die Bauern
Solidarität und Machtlosigkeit m sehr
klar und das war ja gerade auch zu hören
und zu sehen und vielleicht auch zu
riechen was diese Entscheidung ver
Folgen haben kann deshalb kämpfe ich im
Kabinett dafür dass es in dieser Härte
nicht
kommen man glaubt ESD dem mir nicht die
Opposition reih sich heute nicht
zufällig
ein zwei Jahre jetzt so weitermachen das
sieht man hier die Stimmung ist
polarisiert ich verstehe die Bauern auch
die stehen mit dem Rücken zur Wand den
Sprecher der Bundesregierung ganz in der
Nähe und scheinbar in einer anderen Welt
lassen die Proteste recht unbeeindruckt
die allgemeine Einigung und auch da die
grundsätzliche Stoßrichtung bleiben und
jetzt muss man in den einzelnen
Maßnahmen sehen aber da sehe ich jetzt
wenig
änderungswillen innerhalb der
Bundesregierung doch änderungswille
scheint vorhanden habbeck will zwar das
Gesamtpaket nicht wieder aufschnüren
aber man müsse über Alternativen
nachdenken Lindner will das auch und die
SPD ebenso die auch die Pendlerpauschale
anheben will um künftig höhere
Spritpreise
abzufedern das sind mehr Belastung den
Pendlerin und Pendler gerade im
ländlichen Raum nicht aus dem Weg gehen
können und deswegen ist hier gleich aus
unserer Sicht angezeigt zurück zur Wut
und den Bauern wenn die Regierung ihre
Sparpläne nicht komplett streicht kommen
sie Anfang Januar wieder das ist eine
Drohung mit hunderten
pS Ja und der der gegen die komplette
Streichung der Subventionen aber für
eine Überarbeitung war ist mir jetzt aus
Berlin zugeschaltet der
Landwirtschaftsminister von den Grünen
schön guten Abend östem guten Abend Frau
Herr Minister wir den die plte
Streichung der
Agrarsubventionen rückgängig gemacht
also schauen Sie es ist doch klar dass
sich niemand dem schwarzwang entziehen
kann der kommt durch das Urteil aus
Karlsruhe das gilt auch für MeinHaus das
ist mir schon klar aber was jetzt
beschlossen wurde das ist eben dass
nicht nur die KFZ Steuerbefreiung
sondern auch das dieselprivileg
wegfallen soll damit quasi eine
Milliarde nur die Landwirte die
Landwirte leisten ihren Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz die Landwirtschaft hat ihre
Klimaziele erreicht das kann man jetzt
nicht von allen Sektoren sagen und das
ist etwas was viele Landwirte vor den
Kopf stößt weil sie sagen das ist nicht
gerecht beim Agrardiesel kommt dazu es
gibt ja gar kein Ersatz die schweren
Landmaschinen lassen sich nicht anders
betanken also ich kann ihn ja gar keine
Alternative anbieten und da muss man
schon den zn der Landwirte auch
verstehen jetzt führen wir Gespräche und
finden hofentlich Lösung aber Frage aber
die Frage war ja wird das wieder
rückgängig gemacht sie haben jetzt viele
Argumente genannt gute Argumente
sicherlich auch aus Sicht der
Landwirtschaft aber wird das rückgängig
gemacht
ich bin um Nachsicht dass ich das nicht
im heute journal jetzt klären kann aber
wir führen Gespräche ich habe das ganze
Wochenende damit verbracht ich bin auch
dem Bundesfinanzminister Christian
Lindner dankbar dass er angekündigt hat
dass man sich das noch mal anschaut
Robert Habig hat sie jetzt n nicht
geäußert wir führen diese Gespräche mit
dem Ziel dass es so nicht kommen kann
das ist zu viel aber die Argumente die
sie jetzt gerade auch schon genannt
haben die die Bauern heute auch noch mal
formuliert haben die sind ja alle samt
nicht wirklich neu wieso fängt jetzt das
überlegen an und nicht eigentlich
innerhalb dieser vier fast vier Wochen
wo Scholz Harbeck und Lindner verhandelt
haben na ja weil es auch nicht ganz
einfach ist kurzfristig 17 Milliarden
Euro zu mobilisieren und so wie ich gute
Argumente haben haben natürlich auch
andere gute Argumente in ihren Bereichen
worum es mir geht es einfach nch mal
deutlich zu machen die Landwirtschaft
ist bereits zur Veränderung die
Landwirtschaft weiß da gibt's
Klimawandel es gibt Erwartungen aus der
Verbraucherschutz Verbrauchersicht was
Tierschutz angeht aber aber das alles
geht nur wenn man es mit der
Landwirtschaft macht nicht gegen die
Landwirtschaft und die hat die zwei
Jahre in denen ich Minister bin gut
mitgemacht gut begleitet Lob nurark gen
ja ist die ist die Lobby nur stark genug
dann knickt die Ampel ein so könnte man
das ja fast verstehen ich glaube nicht
dass es hier um Lobby geht das also wenn
man eins in der Politik lernen muss dann
ist es das echte klagen vom falschen
klagen und zu unterscheiden das hier ist
kein falsches klagen das ist echtes
klagen hier geht's wirklich um
Existenzsorgen hier geht's um
und jetzt könnte man sagen wie viel
Bauern gibt aber es geht hier nicht nur
um die Bauern es geht um die ländlichen
Räume es geht um das Verhältnis
stadtland und da mache ich mir große
Sorgen dass uns da was wegbricht das
Rechtspopulisten das übernehmen das kann
in niemandes Interesse sein weder im
Interesse der Regierung noch im
Interesse der demokratischen Opposition
robert habbeck hatte ja nach dem
Kompromiss gesagt die Ampel ist
handlungsfähig und trägt die Beschlüsse
gemeinsam offenbar ja dann jetzt doch
nicht denn jetzt wird wieder gestritten
und alles wird wieder in Frage gestellt
das ist doch keine verlässliche und auch
keine vertrauenswürdige Politik die sie
da machen na ja gerade weil ich
Verlässlichkeit gerade weil ich
Planungssicherheit möchte für den
Bereich für den ich zuständig bin geht's
natürlich drum dass die Landwirte auch
sich drauf einstellen können müssen und
eine solche Maßnahme gleich zwei an der
Zahl von heute auf morgen das ist glaube
ich da haben wir überzogen und es ist
glaube ich keine Schande wenn man auch
ehrlich zugibt vielleicht haben wir da
an der Stelle nicht genau sind sie auch
gefragt worden oder hat der
Wirtschaftsminister und der
Finanzminister und der Kanzler überzogen
nein die drei haben sie es nicht einfach
gemacht sie müssen den Auftrag des
Verfassungsgerichtes umsetzen und ich
stehe auch in der Pflicht meinen Beitrag
dazu zu leisten noch mal demenziehe ich
mich nicht und wenn ich jetzt sage
zumindest eine der beiden Maßnahmen muss
zurückgenommen werden dann stehe ich
jetzt auch vor der Aufgabe damit
verbringe ich gerade meine Zeit zu
schauen wo wir das Geld herbekommen sagt
der Agrarminister chem em mir vielen
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit alles Gute
gerne ich danke
Ihnen und im heute journal Update dann
eine Stimme aus der Opposition zu diesem
Thema die cdu-ptikerin Julia klöckler
also die Vorgängerin von gem östemier
und wir blicken in den Nachrichten auf
eine Wahl aus der der Präsident und
Wahlgewinner gundola ziemlich gestärkt
hervorgeht ja in Serbien hat die
vorgezogene Parlamentswahl wie erwartet
den Sieg der der
rechtsnationalen Liste von Präsident wuc
gebracht seine serbische
Fortschrittspartei wird mit absoluter
Mehrheit regieren können die Opposition
spricht von Wahlbetrug und registrierte
450 Verstöße etwa Berichte über
Stimmenkauf und Bestechung von Wählern
kritiker werfen wuic einen autoritären
regierungsziel vor am Abend
demonstrierten tausende Anhänger der
Opposition gegen den
Wahlverlauf
im Gazastreifen gehen die Angriffe der
israelischen Armee gegen die
islamistische Hamas erbittert weiter
beide Seiten melden Tote bei den Kämpfen
im Norden des Küstenstreifens wurde ein
Krankenhaus weitgehend zerstört die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO äußerte
sich
entsetzt US Verteidigungsminister Austin
sicherte Israel bei seinem Besuch in
telaviv weiter volle Unterstützung zu
zugleich kündigte er an mehr humanitäre
Hilfe für die Vertriebenen im
Gazastreifen
bereitzustellen was wenn Russland den
von Putin begonnenen Krieg gegen die
Ukraine gewinnt und dann möglicherweise
nicht aufhört es ist natürlich ein
Horrorszenario keine Frage sehen wir
hier gerade ein falsches Bild das wird
die Regie sicherlich gleich noch ändern
das ist der Besuch der Außenministerin
in Afrika wir kümmern uns jetzt aber
noch mal um die Frage die ich gerade
schon aufgeworfen hatte also was wenn
tatsächlich Russland gegen die Ukraine
gewinnen sollte und dann mit diesem
Angriffskrieg nicht aufhört sondern
möglicherweise andere Länder angreifen
könnte das ist natürlich ein
Horrorszenario und vielleicht ist dieses
Szenario sogar auch ein wenig
übertrieben eventuell aber auf
Eventualitäten will sich der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister nicht verlassen
das 100 Milliarden schuldenpaket oder
wie die Regierung es nennt das
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr ist
ein Hinweis darauf heute ist ein
weiterer deutlicher hinzugekommen
erstmals wird eine bundeswehrbrigade mit
knapp 5000 Männern und Frauen dauerhaft
im Ausland stationiert konkret in
Litauen um dort die NATO Ostflanke zu
sichern über Verteidigung und abschreck
habe ich mit dem Verteidigungsminister
gesprochen zuvor Andreas
Huppert es ist eine Unterschrift von
wahrlich historischer Bedeutung die
Boris Pistorius da in litaauen leistet
eine Unterschrift die verpflichtet
künftig deutsche Kampfverbände dauerhaft
zur Sicherung der NATO Ostflanke
einzusetzen der heutige Tag markiert für
uns für Deutschland und für Litauen aber
auch für mich ein Meilenstein nämlich
die Roadmap zu unterzeichnen für die
briade l Brigade lown heißt Stärkung der
NATO Ostflanke Brigade litown bedeutet
auch bis zu 5000 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten hierher zu verlegen in zwei
Bundeswehrstandorte unweit der
Hauptstadt Vilnius und Brigade lown
braucht modernstes Material an Kampf und
Schützenpanzern an geschützten
Fahrzeugen an Munition an neuester
Kriegstechnik allgemein Brigade litun
kostet also Geld Pistorius ist da in
einem Dilemma weil das Sondervermögen
von 100 Milliarden erst sehr langsam in
die Umsetzung kommt und mittlerweile
nicht für die Beschaffung von
Großprojekten ausschließlich vorgesehen
ist sondern auch den laufenden Betrieb
des
bundeswehralltagsfinanziert und die
ukraineunterstützung und das reicht
natürlich nicht aus ebenfalls noch nicht
ausreichend ist das Personal noch immer
fehlen der Bundeswehr Soldatinnen und
Soldaten für all die anstehenden
Aufgaben in der
Zukunft es braucht auch Investitionen in
militärische R Bedingung Ausstattung
Ausrüstung Material die Familien die
möglicherweise mitreisen
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten Sprachkenntnisse
müssen intensiviert werden also das
braucht noch eine ganze Menge in Zeiten
des Kalten Kriegs bis Ende der 1980er
Jahre verlief die NATO Ostflanke durch
die Bundesrepublik die Alliierten allen
voran die Amerikaner waren Schutzmacht
künftig verteidigt die Bundeswehr in
litown die NATO
Ostflanke es ist ganz entscheidend auch
gegenüber Russland klar zumachen wir
sind verteidigungsbereit und
insbesondere den baltischen Staaten hier
Litauen um das wir uns besonders kümmern
deutlich zu machen wir sind in der Lage
eure Sicherheit zu verteidigen dies hier
in litaauen ist die NATO Ostflanke hier
ist es ernst ja hier muss man sich
vorbereiten durch glaubwürdige
Abschreckung und verteidigungsfähig sein
wenn etwas passiert und deswegen hat das
oberste Priorität und andere Dinge
müssen dann gegebenenfalls dahinter
zurückstehen 20 27 sollen deutsche
Soldaten dauerhaft und kriegstauglich in
Litauen stationiert sein Deutschland
sendet ein klares Signal Richtung Moskau
das da heißt wir stehen bereit die NATO
Ostflanke zu
verteidigen bisher gab es temporäre
rotierende Einsätze jetzt also eine
dauerhafte Stationierung einer
bundeswehrbrigade im Ausland für den
Bundesverteidigungsminister ein
Meilenstein schön guten Abend Herr
Pistorius
schön guten Abend frauali rund 4800
Soldaten Soldatinnen plus Material an
die NATO Ostflanke eine Entscheidung die
natürlich auch Geld kosten wird welche
Kosten kommen denn da auf Deutschland
zu ja zuum meinen muss man sagen es sind
nur in einem bestimmten Umfang
zusätzliche Kosten weil die Brigade ja
Teil sein wird der Division 2025 die der
NATO unterstellt sein wird es geht um
eine Brigade wie gesagt mit 4800
Soldatinnen und Soldaten und und 200
Zivilisten sie wird Aufwachsen in den
nächsten Jahren und es wird natürlich
Material aus den Einheiten dabei sein
die verlegt werden und auch neues
Material die Prüfliste dessen was jetzt
gerade was was da der Bedarf was den
Bedarf ausmacht liegt bei uns im
Bundesverteidigungsministerium wird
gecheckt und dann werden die Beschaffung
ausgelöst aber roundabout können sie es
denn einschätzen was es kosten
wird ne das würde ich eher ehrlich
gesagt lieber erst dann tun wenn wir die
Liste gecheckt haben und sehen was da
ist was beschafft werden muss und wie
die beschaffungsabläufe sind das wäre
jetzt zu früh das alles ist ja auch eine
Reaktion auf die russische Invasion in
der Ukraine beiden der US-Präsident hat
nun vor einem Angriff auf natogebiet
gewarnt rechnen denn auch sie wirklich
damit dass Putin NATO Gebiet angreifen
könnte nicht heute und nicht morgen und
hoffentlich passiert es nie aber alle
Militärexperten gehen davon aus auch
nach den Erfahrungen in der
Vergangenheit dass Russland
zwischen 5 und 8 Jahren braucht um
wieder auf einen rüstungsstand zu kommen
von dem sie glauben könnten das bringt
sie in den Stand anzugreifen oder ein
natoland anzugreifen und zu attackieren
die entscheidende Frage ist also nicht
ob er es tut zunächst mal sondern ob er
es tun wollen könnte und wird und
deswegen werden wir müssen wir alles tun
um uns darauf vorzubereiten und vor
allenen klar zumachen wir wir machen wir
gewährleisten Abschreckung indem wir
sagen ein Angriff auf natogebiet hat
folgen also müssen wir uns auch in den
Stand versetzen diese Abschreckung
realisieren zu können der russische
Präsident sagt das sei alles völliger
Unsinn woran machen Sie das denn fest
also gibt es irgendwelche wirklich
konkreten ernstzunehmenden
Hinweise also ich finde schon amüsant
frauadi dass jetzt ein Zitat von Putin
reicht um eine solche Analyse in Frage
zu stellen Putin hat schon viel gesagt
und dann das Gegenteil gemacht aber
davon mal ganz abgesehen
er hat zuletzt Estland bedroht er hat
Litauen bedroht der hat Moldavien
bedroht er lässt es
er lässt es nicht an Bedrohung Bedrohung
mangeln gegenüber gerade den kleineren
Ländern Dieseits oder jenseits der NATO
territoriumsgrenze von der wie ernst man
das am nende nehmen muss ist eine andere
Frage nur wir müssen klar machen wir
werden durch Abschreckung alles dafür
tun dass es gar nicht dazu kommt dass es
also gar nicht erst zu einem Angriff
kommt also es geht nicht darum aus
meiner Sicht was Putin sagt sondern ob
sie konkrete Hinweise dafür haben dass
er das in Betracht zieht natogebiet
anzugreifen was noch mal was anderes ist
als die Ukraine anzugreifen aber machen
wir da erstmal einen Strich drunter für
Sie Herr Verteidigungsminister ist jetzt
der werrdienst auch wieder eine Option
möglicherweise weil alle mehr aufrüsten
als abrüsten und da lassen sie gerade
auch verschiedene Modelle prüfen Kritik
kommt unter anderen aus den eigenen
Reihen da heißt es dann die Pflicht sei
der falsche Weg warum ist das für Sie
möglicherweise der richtige
Weg ich würde zunächst mal vor
wegschicken wollen dass es darum geht
alle Modelle zu prüfen ich habe mich für
keins entschieden sonst müsste ich ja
nichts mehr prüfen und es geht darum zu
gucken welche Modelle gibt es in anderen
Ländern das schwedische Modell ist kein
pflichtmodell sondern ein freiwilliges
Modell bei dem lediglich ein ganzer
Jahrgang gemustert wird um zu wissen wen
haben wir denn in dem Jahrgang und dann
zu fragen hat dieser oder jene Interesse
werdienst zu leisten oder sich zu
verpflichten und das diesen aus dieser
Gruppe wird dann entsprechend rekrutiert
also es hat mit Pflicht nicht zu tun
aber es gibt auch andere Modelle und ich
will einfach nur das ist mein Job als
Verteidigungsminister auf die Diskussion
vorbereitet sein und die verschiedenen
Modelle kennen und bewertet haben aus
Deutschland bekommt die Ukraine noch mal
ein Unterstützungspaket aus Ungarn der
Slowakei und anderen Ländern ist da
jetzt im Moment nicht ganz so viel zu
erwarten und jetzt könnte auch die USA
als Unterstützer wegbrechen die
Republikaner die blockieren aktuell
Gelder wenn Trump die Wahl nächstes Jahr
gewinnen sollte dann könnte es mit der
Unterstützung ganz aus sein kann die
ukine ohne die USA
gewinnen zunächst mal sind die
präsidentschaftwahen noch nicht gelaufen
und ja wenn das Ergebnis eintrete was
Sie beschreiben dann wäre das schlecht
wäre das ein eine schlechte eine
schlechte Perspektive mit der wir es zu
tun hätten und dann stünden wir vor der
großen Herausforderung zu kompensieren
was dann nicht mehr aus den USA
geleistet würde aber ich würde warten
raten wir warten die in Teilen ja in
Teilen wird es schwierig daran bei heiß
die Maus den Faden nicht ab wir sind
dabei deswegen fahren wir unsere
Unterstützung weiter hoch auch im
kommenden Jahr und werben dafür dass
andere Partner auch tun die Ukraine zu
unterstützen wo immer es geht vor allen
Dingen auch nachhaltig zu unterstützen
durch hochfahren der Produktion von
Munition aber auch z.B durch weitere
Nachlieferung von AIR deffense SYSTEM
weil die für die Existenz der Ukraine
von zentraler Bedeutung sind sagt der
Bundesverteidigungsminister lieben Dank
für die Zeit und für das Gespräch nach
Vilnius
ja sehr gerne
frauali und das Gespräch haben wir
aufgezeichnet und wir machen jetzt
weiter mit Nachrichten zum ersten Mal
ist mehr als die Hälfte des
Stromverbrauchs in Deutschland aus
erneuerbaren Energien gekommen nach
Berechnungen des Verbands der Energie
und Wasserwirtschaft wurden im zu
endehenden Jahr knapp 52% des Stroms von
erneuerbaren Energien erzeugt 5% Punkte
mehr als im Vorjahr
bei der Energiewende spielt auch grüner
Wasserstoff eine wichtige Rolle eine
sehr wichtige Rolle sogar Frank betmann
für uns in Frankfurt wie steht es denn
da um Forschung und Ausbau na ja salop
formuliert es geht voran muss es auch
denn noch befindet sich diese
wasserstoffindustrie ja im Aufbau es ist
also jetzt gerade die Phase wo besonders
viel investiert werden muss frühstens ab
2026 rechnen die Hersteller mit ersten
nennenswerten Mengen an Wasserstoff auf
größere Mengen klimaneutral erzeugten
also grünem Wasserstoff wird man
allerdings noch etwas länger warten
müssen und Unternehmen wie tüssenrupp
die setzen ja auf Wasserstoff wie sieht
die Bilanz der zuständigen
Konzerntochter da aus überraschend gut
überraschend weil es ja das Produkt im
kommerziellen Sinne noch gar nicht gibt
die tüssen gruptochter nusera aber
stellt Anlagen her mit denen Wasserstoff
hergestellt wird das Ganze in einer
Modulbauweise die ersten Anlagen wurden
bereits ausgeliefert deren Nachfrage
steigt ebenso Umsatz und Gewinn erst im
juulai war das Unternehmen an die Börse
gebracht worden bislang war das hier auf
dem Paket keine wirkliche
Erfolgsgeschichte
-17% heute aber stiegt die Aktie die
mittelfristigen Ziele nämlich stark
wachsen zu wollen bestätigte der
Vorstand kurzfristig aber kündigte
nusera heute Verluste im zweistelligen
Millionenbereich an weil die
Anlaufkosten eben hoch sein Frank
betmann vielen Dank
gerne wegen der Verbreitung von
Falschinformationen hat die
EU-Kommission ein Verfahren gegen den
onlineienst X eröffnet seit der
Übernahme durch Elon Musk im vergangenen
Jahr merärt sich die Kritik die
Plattform formorals Twitter tue nicht
genug gegen Falschinformationen und
Hassrede außerdem wird geprüft inwieweit
mit den sogenannten blauen Haken Profile
gefälscht werden können
und jetzt noch eine Meldung vom Sport in
der Fußball Champions League sind die
Partien des Achtelfinals ausgelost
worden Bayern München muss zum Auftakt
der K Phase im Februar zunächst auswärts
bei Lazio Rom antreten Borussia Dortmund
spielt ebenfalls zunächst auswärts bei
PSW einhofen und RB Leipzig empfängt zu
Hause den spanischen Rekordsieger Real
Madrid
so haben Sie Lust
123 Minuten lang einem Mann dabei
zuzugucken wie er Toiletten reinigt mit
Routine in den Tag hineinlebt und dabei
zufrieden zu sein scheint ich weiß es
klingt jetzt nicht wahnsinnig sexy aber
dem Regisseur Wim Wenders ist mit
Perfect days ein kleines Wunder gelungen
es ist ein berührender ein stiller Film
der von einem Hauptdarsteller getragen
wird dass es einem die Schuhe auszieht
Theresa
corero was ist
Glück wen ihrayama zur Arbeit fährt
huscht immer wieder ein zartes Lächeln
über sein Gesicht der Film perfect days
ist diesem Lächeln auf der Spur
eigentlich hat hayama nichts zu lachen
denn er hat wahrlich einen Scheißjob er
putzt Toiletten und die berühmten
designtoiletten in Tokos shibuyaertel
waren Ausgangspunkt für Spielfilm jemand
hat mir von den Toiletten erzählt da war
diese Einladung mir das anzuschauen und
mal zu überlegen ob man irgendwie
vielleicht ein Dokumentarfilm machen
könnte oder sowas und dann habe ich das
alles gesehen habe gesagt das ihr meint
doch nicht im Ernst dass man
Dokumentarfilm über Toiletten ma es ist
dann ein Spielfilm geworden ein ganz
wunderbarer über Hirayama dessen Alltag
einem immer gleichen Muster folgt er
besitzt nicht viel führt ein
bescheidenes Leben und freut sich wenn
er sich jeden Morgen verlässlich seinen
eiskalten dosenkaffee aus dem Automaten
holt bevor er zufrieden zur Arbeit fährt
und er macht es gerne und er geht darin
auf und er macht es mit Hingabe und das
macht sein Leben aus dass alles was er
tut gerne tut und es auch alles so tut
als W es das erste Mal dem Mann der
tiefen entspannt seiner Arbeit nachgeht
stellt Wenders Augen zwinkernd seinen
jungen Kollegen entgegen der stets
gehetzt und hektisch warte kurz ich bin
gleich fertig das ist mein letztes Klub
einst war h y wohlhabend sein altes
Leben hat er hinter sich gelassen in
einer Arbeit die der Allgemeinheit dient
findet er seine
Erfüllung fließt der am Ende ins Meer ja
ins Meer wollen wir hin nächstes Mal das
nächste Mal ist wann auch seiner Nichte
bringt es eine Lebensweisheit bei lebe
im Hier und Jetzt nächstes Mal ist
nächstes Mal und jetzt ist jetzt
nächstes Mal ist nächstes Mal und jetzt
ist jetzt ich glaube das ist für uns
alle im Moment so eine große Sehnsucht
einfacher zu leben und nur nicht so viel
zu haben und nicht so viel auf der
Palette zu haben und was zu machen was
uns ausfüllt der schrammelige
Kassettenrecorder ist so alt wie die
Musik es ist der Soundtrack seines
Lebens allein für den lohnt sich der
Film just up
perfect days ist der perfekte
Weihnachtsfilm wenn Hektik und Konsum
unser Leben bestimmen lässt er uns
Inhalten brauche ich das alles wirklich
oder liegt es ganz woanders das
[Applaus]
Glück wunderbar das Leben im Hier und
Jetzt die große ganz große Kunst und
dass ich die Sendung jetzt alleine zu
Ende bringen musste liegt einfach daran
dass gundol gerade etwaas schwindelig
geworden ist kann passieren aber
Entwarnung es geht ihr wieder besser so
hier meldet sich gegen 0:10 Uhr also
etwas später Laura barnik mit unserem
heute journal Update das war's von mir
und von uns wir sehen uns hier morgen
wieder machen sie es gut wo auch immer
sie sind
[Musik]
tschüss
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja der hohe
Luftdruck der schwindet allmählich und
ein Tief ergreift die Chance und bringt
uns morgen Regen mit dieser Kaltfront
was sie hier noch erkennen ist eine
satte Nordwestlage die sich hier
einstellt und auf dieser Bahn hier
kommen den nächsten Tagen die Tiefs und
es wird sehr windig werden vor allem ab
Donnerstag richtig stürmisch was sie
noch erkennen ist das Hoch hier auf dem
Atlantik das wird 1050 Hektopascal
morgen haben das ist sehr ungewöhnlich
für ein hoch über dem Atlantik wir
schauen auf die Nacht und da gibt's im
Norden Regen sonst nach Süden lockert's
teilweise auf und Richtung Donau da
bildet sich auch Nebel generell im Süden
frostig bis -5° in den höheren Lagen
aber durchaus pluswerte bis 5 auch
pluswerte im Norden z.B 8° in
Schleswig-Holstein morgen dann schwenkt
der Regen allmählich Richtung Mitte im
Süden teilweise Sonnenschein aber an der
Donau weiterhin neblig trüb dort
Temperaturen maximal bis 0° 11° plus
gibt es an den Alpen bei viel Sonne und
9° entlang der Küsten die nächsten Tage
viel Wind und Mittwoch geht's schon los
hier haben sie es mit Wind aus West und
bis Südwest zu tun 3 bis 8° od ab
Donnerstag wird's richtig stürmisch im
ganzen Land vor allem die Nacht auf
Freitag wird dann sehr ruppig und damit
einen schönen Abend